and the lefty david peterson is on the
mound for the mets who have a 309 team
era this year that's the second best in
the major leagues right now
that strength three called down looking
at a knee-high fastball
and now peterson has his first strikeout
of the night
to get to the bottom of the first inning
zach gallon on the mound
zach one and one this year three four
eight era 116
whip
back handed at third by cabrera
and zach allen strands the two odd walk
we've played one in new york
pavon smith the on deck batter
and cabrera goes down swinging good
slider by peterson to get him for his
second strikeout
shortly at first for pavon smith
and ahmed down swinging on the fastball
and that's the third strikeout for
peterson two down in the second
and he walked the pitcher and they're
loaded for la castro here's the set in
the first pitch and le castro gets hit
by a pitch and the d-backs have a
one-nothing lead who would have ever
thought that
the human bruise comes through again a
hit by pitch with the bases loaded
that'll score smith and it's one-nothing
d-bags single a walk to the pitcher and
a hit batter all with two outs have
resulted in a run
and carson kelly has a chance to put a
big-time crooked number up there right
here
[Applause]
well he hit a batter for a run and now
he walks in a run
and as rojas comes across and it's two
nothing
single walk hit batter walk
and the diamondbacks have a two-nothing
lead
christian walker the eighth man the bat
and the diamond back second
[Applause]
he walks in another run and make it
three-nothing diamondbacks and the
wheels are coming off
and that's going to be it here comes
luis rojas
[Applause]
escobar pops one up vr hoping for a play
mccann never saw it the can comes back
and did he corral it he might have he
did wow mccann didn't see that ball when
it first went up and then he had to
sprint to the on deck circle and he did
a remarkable job of making that catch to
end the inning three-nothing
diamondbacks
on and on it goes
for seamer and that's the first
strikeout for gallon two down
and there's strike three gallon gets out
of the second it's three nothing
diamondbacks in new york
cabrera gets the lead from second the
1-1 that one rope it through the right
side past the diving mcneil for a base
hit cabrera will have to stop at third
as the throw comes into the cutoff man
and the bases are now loaded
and for the second time in as many plate
appearances it's zach gallon up there
where the base is full cabrera at third
amid second rojas at first
and gallon hits a ground ball lindor
with the backhand flip out at second the
throw to first is not in time
and a run comes home quite a play by
lindor flipping it to mcneil
though castro hits one into the shift
right at mcneil who gets the force play
to end the inning but not before the
diamondbacks tack on a run driven in by
the pitcher
on the ground nice backhand played by
cabrera the one hop broke gets by walker
lingora will go to second
so the mets have a runner in scoring
position for the first time tonight
here's conforto who walked his first
time up
and that's it toward the middle that's a
baseline lender around third he'll come
home with the first minute run of the
night
michael conforto first pitch swinging
drives in his 10th run of the year and
it's now 4-1 arizona
[Music]
got him to chase the curve ball gallon
gets strikeout number four mets get a
run after three it's 4-1 diamondbacks
he's got a chance to get himself out of
a big jam here an errand walk with the
first two men on but he's retired the
next two now he faces the rookie paving
smith
who's one for two tonight he got the
third the three-run second inning
started with a hit he tops one another
play for gazelleman two unassisted
players for gazellman to end the inning
here's your two strike fastball vr goes
down swinging five strikeouts per gallon
[Applause]
he hits it hard vr with a nice stop
against the speeding le castro the
stretch by alonso he stays on the bag
and the side retired
beautifully done by vr
[Applause]
high in all the rankings but not hitting
with runners
alonzo picks off the liner
but kelly gets back to second base he's
snow cooned by pete at first base on
that rising line drive by escobar for
the second out
that's hit hardened another liner caught
by alonso two in a row
hunter living right strands a runner in
the sixth keeps it a four to one game
there's your ground ball tremendous stop
by walker stepped on second
one that would have had to apply to tag
no chance to get him there they do get
one out and alonzo's in at second base
so alonzo now at second with one out
that's had only one at bat tonight with
a runner in scoring position and
conforto got a base hit so gallon with a
chance to get through six if he can get
through jonathan vr
lined into center field that's down for
a base hit around third alonso heading
home he'll score without a throw
jonathan vr with an rbi single
and the mets pull a little closer it's
now 4-2
ground ball into the shift lindor
hesitated for a moment low throw and
it's too late that's a subtle
miscommunication between mcneil and
lindor it's not the first time this has
happened in the dugout and down the
tunnel we have no idea what happened but
here's what it looked like
smith and conforto ran down
so did vr
so something happened down that tunnel
we have no idea but obviously it drew
the attention of everybody in that
dugout
[Applause]
and we cannot speculate on what it might
be
off of caleb smith knocks it down no
play at second they'll get mcneil at
first
and neato moves up
that helmet is going to die down in the
tunnel i think i just heard it smash
actually in the field
finally squares the ball up and hits it
right back to the map lenore has a home
run in three career at bats against
caleb smith
tonight he's one for three and infield
hit he scored a run in the third
and he drives one to left field down the
line headed toward the corner and that
ball is in here
francisco lindor ties the game with a
two-round homer
nobody ever needed one more
francisco lindora's first city field
home run is second as a met and the mets
have come from four runs down to tie
this game
[Applause]
as drupal cabrera leads off and blasts
one down the right field line that's
going to be an extra base up buried into
the corner played nicely by conforno the
throw to second base and cabrera is
out
what a throw by michael conforto
slider ripped down the
line conforto plays it perfectly off the
wall and throws a perfect
strike
ball was there waiting
cabrera knew it
and now it's lindor who hit the tying
home run in the seventh inning
and lindora showing bunt gets it down
kelly's throw goes to second and they
get the force
so lendura looking to sacrifice but it
goes awry as he couldn't get it far
enough away from home plate so that
leads it to pete alonso
this won't sit in the air to right
playable for paving smith
[Applause]
and we are going to extra innings at
city field extra innings free runner
that broken
but now the mets have the bases loaded
one out so a chance for mazika to be a
hero in his first ever citi field plate
appearance 2-2
zika hits one slowly up the line the
[Applause]
hero in the bottom of the 10th patrick
mazeka in his city field debut his
second big league at bat a walk-off rbi
in the bottom of the 10th and he's lost
his shirt as the mets have taken the
opener from the diamondbacks five
to four